DANA PERINO.
"THE FIVE"."
YOU’VE HEARD THE PHRASE
EMBARRASSMENT OF RICHES.
THAT’S WHAT NEW YORK AS IF HE
REPLACED BRIDGES WITH AWFUL,
HORRIBLE, NO GOOD LAWYERS IN
POWER WHO RUIN PEOPLE’S LIVES
AND LET PEOPLE DIE.
OR YOU CAN CALL THEM NEW YORK
DEMOCRATS.
FIRST THERE’S THE GOVERNOR, WHO
STAFF ADMITS TO COVERING UP REST
HOME DEATHS.
IN A JUST WORLD, WOULD BE OUT.
WE ALSO KNOW ME AS A BROTHER AT
CNN SO WHEN THE REST HOME STORY
WORSENS, WHAT DID HIS COMEDIC
SIDEKICK DO?
TWEET OUT REPUBLICANS.
SADLY HE KEPT THE GIANT Q-TIP AT
HOME IN HIS CLOSET WITH THE
ANKLE WEIGHTS.
JUST AN FYI.
NONE OF THOSE REPUBLICANS WERE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THOUSANDS OF
DEAD.
AND SO TODAY IS THE GOVERNOR
FEELS THE HEAT HE TOOK THE
STRANGE.
WHO’S FAULT COULD BE?
>> COVID DID NOT GET INTO THE
NURSING HOMES BY PEOPLE COMING
FROM HOSPITALS.
COVID GOT INTO THE NURSING HOMES
BY STAFF WALKING INTO THE
NURSING HOME.
WHEN WE DIDN’T EVEN KNOW WE HAD
COVID.
ANYBODY CAN BRING IT IN.
THE DELIVERYMAN BRINGS IT IN.
THE HEATING REPAIR MAN BRINGS AN
END.
THE FOOD SERVICE BRINGS IT IN.
STAFF PERSON GOES HOME, MEETS
WITH THEIR FAMILY, SOMEONE IN
THE FAMILY HAS IT AND THE STAFF
MEMBER COMES BACK IN THE STAFF
MEMBER BRINGS IT IN.
>> Greg: IT’S JUST NOT HIS
FAULT.
IT’S ALL THOSE LITTLE PEOPLE.
BUT YOU’VE GOT TO WONDER, HOW
DOES HE KNOW THIS?
I MEAN, HE BLAMED ALL OF THIS ON
A VOID OF INFORMATION WHICH IS
FUNNY GIVEN WHO CONTROLS THE
INFORMATION.
IT’S HIM.
HOW CAN YOU FORGET THIS?
>> WE ARE BELOW THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE NUMBER OF DEATHS IN
NURSING HOMES.
BUT WHO CARES?
33, 28 DIED IN THE HOSPITAL,
DIED IN THE NURSING HOME.
THEY DIED OF.
>> Greg: AS BAD AS CUOMO IS
AND HE’S BAD, HE HAS ONE ACE IN
THE HOLE.
BILL de BLASIO.
HIS CRIME NOT ONLY RISES BUT
TURNS GRIZZLY UNDER HIM.
SOMEONE RECENTLY ARRESTED FOR
FOUR OTHER VIOLENT ATTACKS.
WHY WAS HE ON THE STREET?
MAYBE HE WOULD GET COVID IN
PRISON.
WHERE CUOMO’S DEFENSES ALWAYS
STEEPED IN DEFENSE OF
ARROGANCE, de BLASIO IS ALWAYS
MINDLESS AMBIVALENCE.
KNOWING THE DISORDER EXONERATES
THE REVOLUTION IN THE PRESS PLAY
ZONE.
AS NEW YORK BLEEDS OUT, PEOPLE
PACK U-HAUL LEAVING THE RICH
ENDINGANDINSANE BEHIND.
THEY CAN FIGHT IT OUT.
THE TICKETS FOR THAT SHOW WILL
BE EASIER TO GET THEN
"HAMILTON."
DANA, I’D LIKE TO SEE YOUR
PERSPECTIVE FROM THE PUBLIC
RELATIONS POINT OF VIEW GIVEN
THAT YOUR HISTORY.
HOW DO YOU THINK THIS THING WENT
TODAY WITH CUOMO?
>> Dana: NOT WELL.
I WOULD SAY PRESIDENTIAL
AMBITIONS ARE OUT THE WINDOW.
I ALSO THINK HIS HOPES OF A
FOURTH TERM AS GOVERNOR ARE
DONE.
I THINK IF HE ANNOUNCES THAT
SOONER THAN LATER, THAT WILL
PROBABLY HELP.
HE’S NOT JUST TAKING INCOMING
FROM THE RIGHT.
HE’S NOW TAKING INCOMING FROM
THE LEFT.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT, ONE OF THE
WORST THINGS THAT HAPPEN AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC WAS
HIM FIGHTING WITH de BLASIO.
UNSORTED WASTING TIME.
I WOULD SAY IF YOU’RE GOING TO
HAVE A PRESS CONFERENCE, WHY
DIDN’T YOU DO IT LAST THURSDAY
WHEN THE STORY BROKE.
THE STORY HAS BEEN OUT THERE
THURSDAY, FRIDAY, SATURDAY,
SUNDAY.
THEN YOU ANSWER QUESTIONS BUT
YOU DON’T ANSWER ALL THE
QUESTIONS.
YOU LEAVE SO MANY THINGS
UNANSWERED.
THAT MEANS IF YOU TALK ABOUT
INFORMATION VOID, THE PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO TRY TO SPILL IT IN.
I WANT TO THANK YOU, GREG.
I WILL NOW START USE ACE WHOLE
AND I WILL NEVER BE BLEEPED
AGAIN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> Greg: I HAVE ANOTHER WORD I
INVENTED.
I WILL TELL YOU LATER.
JUAN, WAS THE TAKE ON THE
PRESSER?
DID HE DO RIGHT BY HIMSELF OR IS
HE IN THE SAME BOAT?
>> Juan: I THINK HE’S LARGELY
THE SAME BOAT.
HE IS TRYING TO EXPLAIN THINGS.
HE’S RIGHT, THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
DEATHS IS THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
DEATHS.
BUT THERE IS NO QUESTION MY MIND
THAT HE COVERED UP WHAT WAS
GOING ON INSIDE THE NURSING
HOMES AND WE HEARD LAST WEEK
JUST THAT FROM ONE OF HIS TOP
AIDES.
IT’S NOT LIKE HE CAN SAY THAT
WAS A MISUNDERSTANDING ALTHOUGH
SHE HAS TRIED TO BACKTRACK A
LITTLE BIT.
THE FACT IS THE FACT.
I THINK WHERE I WOULD SEE IT AS
A LITTLE DIFFERENTLY THAN YOU DO
IS I THINK THE NEW YORK MEDIA,
GOODNESS GRACIOUS.
THEY GO AFTER de BLASIO AND
CUOMO IT SEEMS TO ME.
IT’S AN ALL-OUT HOCKEY BRAWL
EVERY DAY.
WITH THE NEW YORK TABLOIDS, THE
BIG CITY TABLET IS LEADING THE
WAY IN "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
LOVES TO THROW LOW BLOWS AT
CUOMO WHENEVER THEY GET A SHOT.
IT’S DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS
WERE HIGHLY CRITICAL OF CUOMO IN
THIS MOMENT.
OVER THE NURSING HOME SITUATION.
FOR ME, I THINK -- I DON’T KNOW
IT’S THE END OF HIS TIME IN
POLITICS BUT AS A LEADER RIGHT
NOW, HIS BASE WITH DEMOCRATS IS
IN DANGER.
NO QUESTION.
>> Greg: SEAN, YOU ARE IN
POLITICS.
I’M INTERESTED, JUAN IS RIGHT,
IT SEEMS LIKE THE NEW YORK MEDIA
HAS TURNED BUT THEY KIND OF
WAITED UNTIL IT NO LONGER WOULD
BENEFIT TRUMP.
NOW THAT TRUMP IS OUT OF THE
PICTURE, NOW THEY CAN DEAL WITH
THIS BECAUSE THEY KNOW IT WON’T
ACTUALLY ADVANCE TRUMPS POSITION
OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
AM I READING TOO MUCH INTO IT?
>> Sean: I DON’T THINK YOU
ARE.
THEY WANTED TO SAVE CUOMO WHILE
HE WAS BASHING ON TRUMP.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS POLITICS IS
VERY SIMPLE.
BE HONEST WITH PEOPLE.
WE ARE HUMAN, WE MAKE MISTAKES.
IF YOU MAKE A MISTAKE IN YOUR
HONESTY AND YOU APOLOGIZE AND
YOU PROMISE TO DO BETTER, PEOPLE
WILL GIVE YOU A PASS BUT WHEN
YOU SAY THAT THE MISTAKE WAS I
CREATED A VOID AND IT WASN’T MY
POLICY THAT ALLOWED PEOPLE,
SENIORS WHO WERE SICK WITH COVID
TO GO BACK INTO A NURSING HOME
AND INFECT EVERYBODY ELSE.
IT’S ACTUALLY THE STAFF WORKERS
THAT WERE THE PROBLEM.
YOU’RE NOT TAKING
RESPONSIBILITY.
ALSO THEY SHOULD’VE BEEN HONEST
WITH THE NUMBERS, HOW MANY
PEOPLE IN NURSING HOMES ACTUALLY
DIED FROM HIS BAD POLICIES.
IF YOU APOLOGIZE, PEOPLE FORGIVE
FORGIVE.
I’M FROM WISCONSIN.
I’M OUT HERE THIS WEEK AND I WAS
WALKING AROUND, LOOKS LIKE A
PACKERS GAME.
EVERYONE SITTING OUTSIDE WITH
STOCKING HATS AND WINTER
JACKETS.
WHAT A HORRIBLE POLICY TO KICK
EVERYONE OUT OF RESTAURANTS AND
MAKE THEM SIT OUTSIDE AND
28-DEGREE WEATHER.
>> Greg: ALSO WHAT’S
INTERESTING ABOUT THE THINGS
THEY ARE SITTING IN HIS ACTUALLY
BUILDINGS.
ALL THEY WOULD HAVE TO DO IS LET
THE RESTAURANT LEAVE THE WINDOWS
OPEN.
THAT’S WHAT THEY JUST DID.
THEY BUILT A SECOND PART OF THE
RESTAURANT AND LEAVE THE DOORS
AND WINDOWS OPEN.
I DON’T UNDERSTAND.
KATIE, WHERE DO YOU SEE HIS
CAREER GOING?
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT NEW YORK
IN GENERAL?
I’M VERY DEPRESSED.
>> Katie: I WILL NOT GO INTO
MY DEEP FEELINGS ABOUT NEW YORK
IN GENERAL BECAUSE IT WILL TAKE
THE ENTIRE SHOW.
I DO NOT LIVE THERE SO I THINK
YOUR OPINION MATTERS MORE THAN
MINE BUT WHAT HAS HAPPENED TO
NEW YORK IS SAD.
IN TERMS OF CUOMO’S CAREER,
RIGHT NOW LOOKS REALLY BAD BUT
I’M NOT CONFIDENT THAT HE WON’T
FAIL UP ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE
NATIONAL MEDIA HAS GIVEN HIM
SUCH A PASS AT THIS POINT.
I DO THINK THAT THE
INVESTIGATIONS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL AND DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
MAYBE MORE RESULTS THAN CUOMO
WOULD LIKE.
MADE OBVIOUS TODAY HE’S NOT
GOING TO HELP WITH THOSE
INVESTIGATIONS.
TRIED TO SAY SUBPOENAS FROM THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE ASSEMBLY
WERE ILLEGAL.
THAT THEY COULDN’T USE THEM
AGAINST HIM BECAUSE YOU CAN’T
USE THEM FOR LEVERAGE WHEN
THAT’S THE ENTIRE POINT OF THOSE
THINGS.
YOU HAVE DEMOCRATS DEMANDING
THAT THERE BE SUBPOENAS ISSUED,
SEEMS LIKE HE WILL BE IN TROUBLE
FOR SO FOR THE SAKE OF THE
FAMILIES, THERE SHOULD BE SOME
KIND OF LEGAL ACCOUNTABILITY
HERE.
THEY’RE NOT GOING TO GET IT FROM
THE MEDIA.
IF THERE IS NO LEGAL
ACCOUNTABILITY, CUOMO WILL
CONTINUE TO RISE IN HIS
POLITICAL CAREER.
NOW IT LOOKS PRETTY BLEAK.
>> Greg: AND NO ONE TALKS
ABOUT de BLASIO.
IT’S -- I COME I --
de BLASIO WHAT WAS WORSE BUT
NO ONE CARES BECAUSE HE IS NO
LONGER NATIONAL.
HE RAN FOR PRESIDENT.
YOU REMEMBER THAT?